it's officially the holiday season and
it is a time of family friends and many
other things gift giving is one and we
can't forget about our pets i'm so
excited that we've teamed up with petco
where i am all the time because my kids
love animals and we have a lot of
animals um and they're here to show us
how to spoil
those furry friends and here to give us
some favorite gift picks of the season
is our friend vet and fellow animal
lover dr andrew torscha take a look
hi drew i'm here at petco with a few of
my friends and we've got some amazing
gift ideas petco is here to help you and
your pets celebrate the holidays with
unique gifts and essentials at great
prices and you can even get them the
same day so we start our holidays off in
fashion and we've got luna here with our
red buffalo check vest she's ready to
take any holiday adventure and she's
going to stay warm and cozy the whole
time then after our adventures you got
to have a full belly so we've got the
whole hearted puree variety pack it's
fun interactive way to reward your kitty
and it even makes a great meal topper
for added flavor after your feast it's
time to relax so we've got our all
spruced up christmas tree pet bed we can
curl up and take a nap and even play
with the fun plush candy cane toy not
only is it a nice bed for your kitty but
it's also a great holiday decoration
there are more gift ideas at petco so be
sure to check them out this holiday
season thanks drew thank you andrew i
can't wait to start shopping for our
dogs douglas and lucy and our cats lucky
and peach we also just adopted some new
kitties and then there's jeremy the
bearded dragon
so thank you for all the helpful tips
[Music]